Hogwarts Legacy has some truly amazing
spells a talent tree to make a lot of
them even stronger and quite a few
builds that are ridiculously powerful
So today we're ranking every spell in
the game from the essential spells to
the utility room of requirement spells
and even the unforgivable curses no this
is not another tearless video we'll have
to make some really tough decisions
along the way because there can only be
one to claim the top spot on our list
let's start things off at the bottom
number 34 and we have the Beast petting
brush and no it's not that I don't love
the magical beasts in the game because I
absolutely do but it's the fact that the
brush takes up a spot in our slottable
spell list and you only have a maximum
of 16 slots available even when you're
fully upgraded not to mention the fact
that it's not really even a spell and it
can only be used in the room of
requirement so with these first few
spells here you're gonna see a common
theme because there are a handful here
that to me it seems like they could have
been contextual only certainly not
spells to take up a slot on our spell
diamond that could otherwise be used for
more combat or puzzle-oriented Spells at
number 33 we have the Beast feed utility
and I gave this one a spot above the
brush because you'll eventually unlock
feeders that you can use inside the
vivariums so you'll actually never need
to slot this one again unless you just
want to manually feed one of your
magical beasts mostly though this one
has the same problems as the Beast brush
before it alright for the next three 32
31 and 30 we have the Transfiguration
spells for altering Conjuring and the
vanishing spell evanesco I rate these
just above the Beast ones because they
actually are spells and I do love the
fact that our character has their wand
out as the Performing these actions the
animations are also absolutely fantastic
look like they were right out of the
movie and each spell does what it's
intended to do unfortunately though like
the B spells there's really no need to
have these taking up valuable slots in
our spell diamond because the only place
they can be used again is here in the
room of requirement I love the fact that
they're spells and again the animations
are great but it would be nice if they
belong to a different set and only
showed up when you're inside the room of
requirement number 29 the knapsack this
one gets a slight bump over the others
because it actually is something that
you'll use out in the open world of
Hogwarts Legacy this charm bag is how
you will rescue and hold magical bees
that you find when you're out exploring
I think maybe there could have been a
better way to map this one in game so it
didn't have to take up one of the
slottable Spells maybe just another
contextual prompt when say you're locked
onto a nearby magical Beast would that
have worked I don't know maybe maybe not
I'm not a Game Dev but anything to free
up more spell slots I think would have
been nice all right so the Beast and
Transfiguration spells are out of the
way now we start to move into the more
conventional spells of the game and at
number 28 we have repero which allows
you to quickly return certain damaged
objects to their former State the spell
itself it's actually awesome the
animations are great when you're
repairing but it's just so sparingly
used in the game that it's hard for me
to rank it much higher usually it's a
very specific instance where a puzzle or
Mission requires you to repair a
specific object in the game not always
but that is what I found more often than
not moving on to number 27 we have the
basic cast this is one of the first
Bells you learn in the game
unfortunately it does not take up a slot
in the spell diamond you can also spam
this one as many times as you want no
cooldown the spell itself does do minor
damage to most enemies but its most
important function is to keep your combo
meter going and even juggling enemies as
you wait for your more powerful spells
to become available after the their
cooldowns alright now at this point we
have to start making some really tough
decisions guys truth be told many of the
Spells ahead can actually be very useful
in the right context and made even more
powerful with certain Talent upgrades
and gear traits these are really ranked
help I like to play the game and what
worked best for me so don't get too
angry I know you guys are gonna let me
know in the comments either way though
how much you love or hate my list but at
number 26 we have what is arguably the
most iconic spell from the old school
Harry Potter games and that is flipendo
absolutely love that they put fopindo in
as a nod to the previous games in the
series in Hogwarts Legacy this is yet
another wonderful example of fan service
and the spell even functions similar to
how it did back then the only problem
here is that it's far outclassed by many
of the other spells in the game and even
though we start the game as a fifth year
we become very powerful very quickly in
this game working in its favor though
fopindo does have a very short cooldown
and can be particularly helpful against
the burrowing spiders and trolls right
after they slam their clubs next on our
list at number 25 we have the essential
spell alohomora which will grant access
to a variety of locked rooms and loot
chests throughout the world of Hogwarts
Legacy the spell does belong in the
essential category I certainly agree
with that you'll absolutely need the
most basic version of the spell and even
the tier 2 and tier 3 versions if you
want to unlock everything in the game
even in its most upgraded form however
alohomora is not an instant unlock
you'll need to complete a lock picky
minigame every time you use the spell
and while initially was not a fan of
this mini game it's grown on me somewhat
over time I can usually knock these out
pretty quickly our next spell coming in
at number 24 is one of the classics from
the series Wingardium Leviosa not to be
confused with levioso despite what you
guys keep telling me in the comments
we'll get to that one shortly when
guardian Leviosa levitates and controls
a movable object and it works very well
pretty much does exactly what it says
while there are occasions where you may
not be able to move an object that you
think you should be able to move for the
most part this one works as expected it
doesn't really factor into combat much
unless that is you want to levitate
objects and then bash them into foes
which actually does quite a bit of
damage believe it or not but there's
another spell coming up on our list that
basically removes the need of you ever
needing to slot when guarding Leviosa on
its own and we'll get to that one
momentarily for number 23 though it's
the control spell aresto momentum this
one will slow both objects so it can be
helpful with certain puzzles as well as
enemies aresto can be really useful in
the middle of a hectic battle especially
if you want to slow or stop a Target
while dealing with other minor enemies
in the area it's also good at making it
easier to catch magical creatures in the
knapsack because you can slow them
before trying to capture or rescue I
mean alright I have a feeling the next
one here might be a bit controversial
but I'm gonna rank incendio at number
22. okay look I actually used incendio
quite a bit through my first playthrough
fire spells definitely definitely
important especially for dealing with
spiders and in theory my biggest issue
with incendio though is that it's very
short range and that's just not how I
like to play this game to be fair the
upgrade is nice because it will cast a
circle of flames out around you that's
really useful if you're getting sworn by
a group of enemies I just never felt
like it was doing all that much damage
even though the description says the
spell deals significant damage look I
still think it's used full overall but
there's another fire spell that I prefer
again works better from range and we'll
see that here a bit later on the list at
number 21 though we have another iconic
spell from the Potter series and it's
lumos which will let you see in dark
areas or solve puzzles that require
extra light now if we were just ranking
on sound effects alone lumos would have
to be number one because they have
absolutely nailed that instantly
recognizable sound from the movies lumos
it sounds just so perfect here and the
visual effects look really nice too the
four spell depulso is at number 20 on
our list and it's funny this one falls
in the force category because it draws
so many comparisons to the force push
ability from Star Wars and it's very
similar the spell itself actually does
no direct damage however enemies and
objects can both be launched into each
other with destructive results or you
can just launch enemies off the side of
a cliff it's also quite useful in many
of the game's puzzles bombarda takes the
number 19 spot and this spell deals
heavy damage on impact and also includes
an explosion that can destroy heavy
obstacles and even hit surrounding
enemies okay bombarda would probably
rank higher on my list if it did fire
damage as well but if you cast a spell
on something like an inferious you'll
notice it doesn't do any damage at all
which indicates there's no fire damage
being inflicted here the bombarded
Mastery Talent upgrade will enable an
explosive blast with an even greater
area of effect it's also a nice one to
blast off at Red barrels to get a
massive explosion just don't get too
close coming in at number 18 we have the
four spell descend know which again
won't do any direct damage however if
you're able to slam enemies into the
ground they will take damage from the
impact previously Airborne enemies such
as those who may be levitating with
levioso will take even greater damage
when they hit the ground descendo is
also a great setup spell it throws
enemies off balance before you hit them
with another more powerful spell very
versatile great combo starter as well
now that other spell that we just
mentioned lebioso it's number 17 on our
list this control spell levitates both
enemies and objects but not to be
confused with Wingardium Leviosa it does
not allow movement of the objects once
they're levitating levioso is used very
frequently in many of the game's puzzles
and can help you reach higher areas by
hovering blocks which you can then climb
to reach new areas it's also perfect for
juggling and maybe the best setup spell
for combos in the whole game once you
have an enemy levitating they're really
at your mercy until the effect wears off
the levioso Mastery Talent even lets you
levitate multiple enemies at the same
time if they're in close proximity now
if you're a fan of stealth then number
16 is absolutely vital for you 2 and
it's the disillusionment charm which
causes you to blend into your
surroundings and makes it difficult for
others to detect you it's not total
invisibility like Harry's cloak but it's
perfect for sneaking up or approaching
enemies undetected you can even skip
huge areas of enemies taking advantage
of this charm it becomes even more
powerful if you pursue upgrades in the
stealth talent tree I think the biggest
knock for me here though is that I just
love the combat so much more than
stealth in this game which normally is
not the way I like to play games I
usually love stealth but here the combat
is so fun I really just don't find
myself caring about Stealth that much
and that takes us to number 15 where we
have my favorite fire spell in the game
confringo I prefer this one to incendio
primarily because of its range and the
talent upgrade for this one is awesome
confrinco is a long-range bolt of fire
that will deal damage on impact as long
as the enemies remain on fire any
subsequent hits on the enemy will result
in incendiary bursts the confringo
Mastery Talent though takes this to a
whole nother level with this unlocked
any confringo impact will produce fiery
bolts that seek out other enemy targets
to me confrio is also more useful for
puzzles because you can have more
accuracy by lining up the spell with a
left trigger and you can do it from a
pretty decent range as well Harry Potter
himself May disagree with this next one
being so low but for Hogwarts Legacy I'm
ranking Expelliarmus at number 14 on our
list look everybody knows this was
Harry's go-to spell throughout the
original series and admittedly it saved
his life on more than one occasion it's
also pretty strong here in Hogwarts
Legacy and can take certain enemies out
of the battle for a moment forcing them
to stop and retrieve their wands before
being able to cast again it doesn't only
disarm those with wands however it will
also rip weapons away from most other
standard enemies in the game and on top
of that it deals damage to all enemy
types even if they don't carry weapons
so you don't have to limit the use of
Expelliarmus to only armed enemies it
works on creatures as well okay look the
spell is already strong on its own but
there's even a dark arts talent tree
upgrade that will also give it the curse
inducing effect and any enemies that are
cursed take even more damage now
speaking of curses and the dark guards
at lucky number 13 we have our first
unforgivable curse on the list and it's
Cruces yo this Bell will cause most
enemies to Rive in pain taking damage
over time and places the cursed status
effect on enemies another ability of the
spell is to break through any Shield
type and this is going to be true for
all of the unforgivable curses really
the only thing holding crucio back is
the fact that it doesn't work on enemies
like in Fury or the enchanted Knights as
they cannot feel pain make no mistake
though crucial is really powerful and
when used in conjunction with other
options that take advantage of this
curse effect it can be tremendously
useful in battle as powerful as the
unforgivables are though don't sleep on
another late game spell the
transformation controls fell which comes
in at number 12 on our list I'll be
honest at first I did not appreciate the
power of the spell it will transform
objects and enemies into alternate forms
whether puzzle solutions or harmless
knickknacks the effect does not last
forever though and the enemies will
eventually turn back to normal there are
also stronger enemies in the game where
the spell really won't have any effect
you'll only unlock the ultimate power of
this spell if you go into the Spells
talent tree and use the final upgrade
there which changes everything this
Talent upgrade will change a key aspect
of the spell and that is by transforming
enemies into explosive objects instead
of harmless knickknacks and once you
transform an enemy into an explosive
Barrel you can almost always get two
immediate Kos by using the ancient magic
throw prompt that appears when the enemy
is transformed so you destroy the enemy
that you just changed into the explosive
Barrel as well as the enemy or group of
enemies getting hit by the barrel it
doesn't stop there though even though
the spell does not appear anywhere under
the dark arts talent tree if you have a
few different cursed enemies on the
battlefield and then you cast this spell
on one of them you can get an instant KO
on all of them at once there are also
some pretty humorous uses for this spell
as well but I won't spoil them all here
why don't you just try and see how many
different things in the game that you
can cast this transformation spell on
and that takes us to number 11 just
outside the top 10 we have glacias the
only reason glacius is not even higher
on the list is because on its own it
really doesn't do much it's really a
setup spelling and it is absolutely my
favorite setup spell in the game it will
freeze enemies in their tracks and while
Frozen they'll take even more damage
this is the main reason that I prefer it
to rest a momentum even though it does
not have the dark arts curse option like
Resto then there's also the talent
upgrade for glacias this one falls under
the Spells talent tree I absolutely
think it's worth it glacius Mastery will
give you a blast of damaging ice shards
anytime you strike an enemy that's been
frozen by glacias so you can start
imagining some of the incredible combos
you can do using glaciers as your setup
in fact my absolute favorite combo in
the game is anything that ends with
glacias followed by the number 10 spell
on our list defendo this damage spell
slashes objects and enemies from afar
and Deals considerable damage this is
one on our list that really isn't made
that much better by its Talent upgrade
which grants Defender the ability to
slice through additional targets if
they're in close proximity to one
another but davindo is just really
powerful on its own right out of the
gate you can use levioso on a dog bog at
just the right time to levitate them by
their tongue and then cast a window for
an instant KO even on the game's hardest
difficulty and then the combo I
mentioned glacias into defindo guys
there's a complete set of different ways
that you can do this using other spells
like Expelliarmus sindo even accio for
absolutely devastating results for
number nine we have another one for
stealth fans out there and it's
petrificus totales now to be totally
honest with you here as I mentioned
before I love the combat so much in this
game I almost always prefer that over
the stealth as a spell though I have to
get petrificus totalus it's due because
when used in conjunction with the
disillusionment charm it's really potent
mainly because it's an instant takedown
on most of the normal enemies in the
game you can even make things much
easier for yourself in a battle if you
first go around and kind of thin out the
field by quietly taking out a few
enemies with stealth you can also use
petrificus totalus immediately after
glacias orabesto momentum but only if
you aren't being detected by other
enemies at number eight it's time for
our second unforgivable curse and here
we have imperio this spell will
temporarily Force enemies to fight as if
they were your companion they'll take
reduced damage from other enemies but
also take on the cursed status effect
which means they'll take more damage
from you when you're finished and ready
to dispose of them what's insane about
imperio is that you can use it on some
of the tougher enemies in the game like
trolls which can really help out a ton
with crowd control not only that there's
a talent upgrade where an enemy under
your control with imperio will actually
curse other targets with each successful
strike there's really no doubt about it
guys in Hogwarts I can see the
unforgivables they're incredibly
powerful I mean I say that as someone
who played through my first playthrough
not using any unforgivables outside the
dark arts battle arena but the truth is
the truth guys they are ridiculously
powerful and they give you the
opportunity to set up some truly amazing
builds and number seven on our list
though it's actually an essential spell
here called the ancient magic throw
which was previously referred to as a
pugno before the devs opted to tie the
spell to our ancient magic ability
Instead This spells summon objects and
then throws the objects at targeted
enemies it's very useful for breaking
through Shield charms without having to
worry about matching the correct color
shield the ancient magic throw is vital
to anyone who wants to master the combat
in Hogwarts Legacy it does a great
amount of damage and works so well with
the other spells in the game like the
transformation spell it also has no
cooldown does it take up a slot in your
spell diamond and it's really only
limited by the amount of throwable
objects around you but again when you
pair this with the Transfiguration spell
you can really maximize and use it to
its full potential I also highly
recommend the ancient magic throw
expertise Talent which is under the core
talent tree having this gives you the
ability to perform what is absolutely my
favorite thing to do with the combat in
the whole game and that is to use a
disarmed enemy's weapon and send it
hurtling back toward them it's part of
the reason those Enchanted Knights are
some of my favorite enemies in the game
to fight because you can use this spell
quite often against them up next and
arguably the most important spell for
puzzle solving in the game we have the
summoning charm Akio Akio can summon a
variety of objects and enemies to close
range so it ends up being very useful in
both puzzles and combat what makes it
even more helpful for puzzle solving
though is also the fact that it has the
ability to automatically cast Wingardium
Leviosa once you've unlocked that spell
so remember when we ranked when guardium
earlier I said there was no need to
actually slot it well it's because accio
will automatically cast when guardian
Leviosa even says it in the description
here so it's definitely intended and it
happens once the object reaches your
character as long as you're still
holding down the right trigger Accu is
also just as useful in battle though
because with the accumastery talent it
can pull multiple enemies in close
setting them up for a close range cast
of say incendio or bringing them
together for a bombarda or glacious
explosion and now we have reached the
top five spells in Hogwarts Legacy and
really quick I just want to say if
you've been enjoying this video guys so
far consider hitting the Subscribe
button Bell icon on really helps out the
channel a lot and I would certainly
appreciate your support getting to
number five now we have the ancient
magic attack this is yet another
essential spell and can only be
activated when the ancient magic meter
is filled you only need to have one
segment of the meter film though and
then you'll be able to unleash a
devastating attack that deals massive
damage to the targeted enemy and can
break through any Shield charm there are
multiple unlocks throughout the game to
further extend your ancient magic meter
and even traits that you can apply to
gear as well as upgrades that will help
you fill this meter even faster the
biggest benefit it has to some of the
other powerful spells in the game is
when you have a few of these built up
there's no cooldown between them of
course on the other side of that if your
meter completely Runs Out you will have
to refill it before casting again but
this spell can be used in so many
different ways you can use it to start
out a fight and instantly take out one
of the enemies from the field or you can
save it for only when you're in trouble
or maybe you want to wait and try to do
some big damage on the large bosses also
some of the best animations in the game
happen with the ancient magic attack
this is random and it varies based on
the enemies that you're fighting really
the only spell that can rival the
ancient magic attack is the killing
curse of Vada cadaver which takes not
the number one spot the number four spot
on our list the description for a vatica
diver is the shortest one in the game
and it does exactly what it says it will
do on any enemy regardless of their size
or their health which keeps it true to
its nature from The Source material this
is only balanced by a lengthy cooldown
time for the spell but even with that
Avada Kedavra is absolutely one of the
most powerful spells in the game if
you're going down the dark path it's
also by far the spell that fans
requested the most in the lead up to the
game frankly it surprised many of us
when we learned that it would not be
reserved only for like a finisher spell
but it actually would be a slottable
spell that you can cast anytime of
course once that cooldown refills and
again no surprise here but the dark arts
talent tree yeah it's gonna make AK even
more overpowered by giving it the
ability to instantly take out every
single cursed enemy on the battlefield
what's more there's yet another dark
arts Talent called cursapper where
defeating a cursed enemy restores a
portion of your health so guys and gals
if you've been excited for the dark arts
and Hogwarts Legacy you're going to be
very very happy with the vodka davra but
what could possibly top the ancient
magic spells and even the unforgivables
on our list what is left for the top
three well at number three we have
probably the spell you've cast more than
any other in the game reveillo this is
another spell in the essential category
and throughout the game it's mapped to
the left button on your d-pad ravelio
highlights a variety of useful and
interactive Targets in the world
including hidden objects puzzle items
loot enemies and more now truthfully you
could probably make it through a lot of
the game without ever using this spell
other than the sections where it's
required but if you're a Trophy Hunter
if you like to find Collectibles
rivellio revelio revelio everywhere you
go reveillo for puzzle solving and
general exploration it will be your
tried and true spell to reveal secrets
and assist with solving puzzles it's
also helpful in combat as you can scope
out enemies in the area and know exactly
what you're up against before the fight
begins there's also no cooldown
whatsoever plus you can even use it
while riding your broom making it the
only spell in the game that you can cast
while flying add in the extended radius
Talent upgrade it's even more useful
when you're flying with all of the
points of interest it can reveal coming
in at number two we have yet another
essential spell and this one is Stupify
which has has the ability to stun
enemies setting up follow-up attacks in
its unupgraded form it deals no direct
damage but stunned enemies will take
extra damage on any follow-up attacks if
you're playing on any difficulty other
than hard it will also break through any
color shield charm now if you aren't in
the habit of holding protego after
blocking it's time to start focusing on
that because using Stupify in
conjunction with protego is so
incredibly important for managing
multiple enemies on the battlefield now
we talked a lot about upgrades here
today upgrading stupefy with additional
talents yeah it's going to make it even
better it's going to give it the ability
to actually cause damage when it hits
and another dark arts Talent where it
can even cause that curse inducing
effect it's so versatile and the fact
that you can cast it with every single
use of ortego makes it incredibly
powerful and one that you will
absolutely want to master and at number
one on our list of best spells in
Hogwarts Legacy we just hinted at it we
have the essential Shield charm protego
now you may be surprised to see this one
rank above a spell like Avada Kedavra
but the reality is you won't unlock AK
until very late in the game whereas
protego it's a spell you're going to
learn very early on and again it is
vital to mastering combat in this game
regardless of which type of build you're
playing there will almost always be
moments in the game where you need to
use the shield charm and even though the
spell is primarily a defensive one you
can also wait until the last possible
moment to cast protego before an impact
and this is going to result in what's
known as a perfect protego this perfect
protego will instantly damage any melee
attackers but will also reflect back
enemy projectiles and even break through
Shields there's also no cooldown and
even though some spells are unblockable
using protego in conjunction with
Stupify and its curse effect plus the
benefits of a perfect potato to me are
more than enough to Warrant giving it
the top spot on our list and I break
down some of my favorite combat tips in
the video showing up now on the right
side of your screen check that one out
next as always guys thank you all so
much for watching I'll talk to you again
soon